This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是真人。你有帮助他人做出真正改变的愿望吗？拉西特学院，为你提供“依赖与老年护理”项目。获取那些
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and and dependents. Construise a career enriching
对于陪伴和支持那些面临健康及依赖问题的人至关重要的技能。打造一份丰富自己职业生涯的工作，
to service of the community Francophone of all the country. Don't the Coney in French,
服务于全国各地的法语社区。在法兰西语境中认识他们，
it's possible with the CET. Visit CollageLac C.A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
通过CET是完全可能的。今天就访问CollegeLac C.A.，这是由全国健康培训联合会发起的一个倡议，
of Formation in Health Supporting, supported by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up.
得到加拿大卫生部的支持。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变黑了。这把我吓坏了。恶魔，醒醒。
I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我就是那个亲眼目睹克里瓦克和德皮波行凶的女人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚时表现得毫无悔意，显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我要把这带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨骼山谷》中的恶魔采石场。
Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
快乐至关重要，它也有些捉摸不定，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开始你的旅程，走向一个更快乐的生活，《快乐101》。这是一个由我霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中聊天。打开你的免费IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《快乐101》并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比的《快乐101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nandes
每个人都把我当成一个橄榄球运动员，但在此之前，我首先是个普通人。每天我仍在学习如何与我出生以来的问题、错误、人际关系和情感共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里奥托内德斯
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets.
并在IHard Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。你的丈夫并不是你认为的那样。你的身体也不是你想象的那样。你的身份是由一段秘密历史塑造的。我是达尼·夏皮罗。这些只是我将在《家庭秘密》第十四季中探讨的一些震撼人心的故事。
He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. I want to talk today about a situation or like the deep state of human longing that I receive
他有点把我推开说，让开。然后他走出前门，跳上一辆车开走了。那是我最后一次见到他。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《家庭秘密》第十四季。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨我们二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，
a whole lot of questions about and a whole lot of stories about all the time. Finding yourself kind of embroiled in a one-sided love affair with somebody who doesn't want you back. I get messages about this all the time and I got a message this week from a listener who has been in a situation like this for over two years with a co-worker of hers. She had like a brief kind of romantic encounter with him, like back in the day. They kind of went their separate ways after, like, he made the decision to break it off. But she was explaining to me, like even after he's gone and moved on, he's got a new girlfriend,
当然，我们一如既往地剖析我们二十岁的心理。今天我想谈谈一种情况，或者说是一种人类渴望的深层状态，我收到了
her attachment to him hasn't faded. And it's making it really hard to work. It's making it really hard to focus. The thing about this is, when you're in, in it, it feels all-consuming. And like you are the only person in the world who could be so silly or who is so stuck on somebody you know you can't be with. It feels like how rational, how strange that our minds cannot let somebody go despite all the reason in the world that this person is not right for us. But really, it is so much more common than you think. Maybe that doesn't make the
大量关于这方面的问题和故事。发现自己陷入了一种单相思的纠葛中，对象是一个并不想要你的人。我经常收到关于这方面的消息，这周我收到了一位听众的消息，她和她的一个男同事陷入这种状况已经超过两年了。她曾经跟他有过一段短暂的浪漫经历，就在过去。后来他们分道扬镳了，因为他决定结束这段关系。但她向我解释说，即使在他离开并开始新生活、有了新女朋友之后，
yearning hurt any less, but I think it does mean that we can offer a bit of an exercise. We can offer a bit of an explanation as to why this happens. From a more psychological angle, like there is a reason why we find ourselves so hooked on people we know we can't have. The very fact that we cannot have them is what deepens this obsession so much. And there's science and evidence to prove why that is. It may feel like so frustrating and annoying and heartbreaking at times. But I think understanding the biological underpinnings of this, the social underpinnings, the psychological underpinnings is really important. So that's what we're going to talk about today, as well as some strategies to kind of move through this situation of unrequited love and to essentially
她对他的依恋并没有消退。这使得工作变得非常困难。这使得集中注意力变得非常困难。关于这一点，当你身处其中时，它会让人感觉一切都被吞噬了。就像你是世界上唯一一个会这么傻，或者会死心塌地爱着一个你知道无法在一起的人的人。这感觉多么不合理，多么奇怪，尽管有世界上所有的理由说明这个人并不适合我们，但我们的内心就是无法放手。但实际上，这种情况比你想象的要普遍得多。也许这并不能让这种
understand why you have found yourself perhaps in a pattern of wanting people who don't want you, because there is a lot to be said about our motivations behind this and why we end up finding ourselves in these relationships maybe all too often. So without further ado, let's get into it. If you want to understand why we want the people who don't want us, you have to understand the psychology and more specifically the biology of the chase. At its very core, our attraction, to somebody else is not just emotional. It is a deeply chemical experience driven by some powerful neurotransmitters you're probably very familiar with, things like dopamine, serotonin, adrenaline, just to name a few. When we first meet somebody and feel like a romantic sensation,
渴望带来的痛苦减轻，但我觉得这确实意味着我们可以做一些练习。我们可以提供一些解释，说明为什么会发生这种情况。从更心理学的角度来看，我们发现自己迷恋那些明知无法得到的人，是有原因的。恰恰是因为我们无法拥有他们，才使得这种痴迷变得如此深重。有科学和证据来证明这是为什么。有时这可能会让人觉得非常沮丧、烦人和心碎。但我认为理解这背后的生物学基础、社会基础、心理基础真的非常重要。所以这就是我们今天要谈论的内容，以及一些帮助你度过这种单相思状况的策略，并且本质上
kind of blossoming, our brain is just like flooded with feel-goody chemicals. and feelings which tell us to pursue this person, fixate on them, think about them, win them over, make them the object of our desire. We have a natural biological drive towards love because we are social beings and we crave partnership, we crave being seen, we crave creating these strong bonds. Now when the person reciprocates our feelings, we have a fabulous equation where the chemicals are flowing steadily from both sides, from them to you, you to them. There's no confusion, but just rewarded by their behavior and you're rewarded by what it feels like to belong and feel, I don't know, chosen by somebody. This feels good. Love obviously feels good. But when
理解为什么你可能会发现自己陷入了一种渴望那些不想要你的人的模式，因为关于我们背后的动机以及为什么我们最终可能会过于频繁地发现自己处于这些关系中，有很多值得探讨的地方。废话不多说，我们切入正题。如果你想了解为什么我们想要那些不想要我们的人，你必须了解这种追求的心理学，更具体地说是生物学。在其核心，我们对另一个人的吸引不仅仅是情感上的。这是一种深刻的化学体验，由一些你可能非常熟悉的强大神经递质驱动，比如多巴胺、血清素、肾上腺素，仅举几例。当我们第一次遇到某人并感受到一种浪漫的感觉时，
somebody doesn't reciprocate our interest, this feels addictive. Here's the thing most people don't tell you about dopamine. It's not actually the happiness or pleasure chemical. It's the anticipation chemical. There's this wonderful 2010 paper, which talks about how dopamine doesn't spike when we get something. It spikes in the pursuit of something. It drives craving. It drives our motivation to chase, to pursue, to impulse by, to want the cookie, to anticipate the reward, to like the person who doesn't like us back. This means it can be very easily hijacked when we are yearning or longing for something because we're getting these massive dopamine spikes that aren't met with the reward or fulfillment of the desire.
这种感觉开始萌芽，我们的大脑就像被感觉良好的化学物质和感受所淹没，这些感受告诉我们要追求这个人，迷恋他们，想着他们，赢得他们，让他们成为我们欲望的对象。我们对爱有一种天然的生物驱动力，因为我们是社会性动物，我们渴望伴侣，渴望被看见，渴望建立这些牢固的联系。现在，当这个人回应我们的感受时，我们拥有了一个极好的等式，化学物质从双方源源不断地流动，从他们到你，你到他们。没有困惑，只有他们的行为带来的回报，以及属于某人并感觉，我不知道，被某人选择的感觉带来的回报。这感觉很好。爱显然感觉很好。但是当
This is quite literally the chemical basis of addiction, wanting something, needing something, desiring it deeply to the point where it's all we can think about, not receiving it, crashing or receiving it and feeling even better, but then needing more. Now, when somebody doesn't like you back, but you occasionally see them around, like they occasionally like your Instagram stories, you have like somewhat of a history where maybe they once showed you affection, now they don't anymore. What you're essentially experiencing is something called intermittent reinforcement. You occasionally get interactions, spikes of what you want, what could be. And that sets off your dopamine systems because they already have a low,
有人没有回应我们的兴趣时，这感觉就像是上瘾了。大多数人不会告诉你关于多巴胺的一点是：它实际上并不是快乐或愉悦的化学物质。它是期待的化学物质。有一篇2010年的精彩论文，谈到多巴胺在我们得到某东西时并不会激增。它在我们追求某东西时激增。它驱动渴望。它驱动我们去追逐、去追求、去冲动购物、去想要饼干、去期待回报、去喜欢那个不喜欢我们的人的动机。这意味着当我们对某事渴望或向往时，它很容易被劫持，因为我们得到了这些巨大的多巴胺峰值，却没有得到欲望的回报或满足。
a low threshold. And it makes you feel really, really good. There's like these little spikes followed by these big crashes. But the anticipation of, or the expectations of things changing, the anticipation that your next interaction, your next moment could be the moment when things, they fall in love with you, keeps you hooked. Each small signal of attention, a text, a glance, a moment of connection feels disproportionately rewarding because it's unpredictable. That inconsistency actually strengthens the attachment. Over time, your brain, like you're in such a heightened state of craving that it feels like genuine attraction. The anxiety, the obsession, the excitement, it's so intense that intensity obviously registers deeply with our brain,
这简直就是成瘾的化学基础，想要某样东西，需要某样东西，深深地渴望它，直到满脑子都是它，却没有得到它，崩溃了，或者得到了它却感觉更好，但接着又需要更多。现在，当有人不喜欢你，但你偶尔能见到他们，比如他们偶尔给你的Instagram快拍点赞，你们有一点历史，也许他们曾经对你表现出喜爱，而现在没有了。你本质上经历的是一种叫做间歇性强化的东西。你偶尔会得到互动，得到你想要的、可能得到的事物的峰值。这会触发你的多巴胺系统，因为它们已经有了一个较低的、
and therefore it can be mistaken for actual chemistry and for something that's very, very real to your mind, even if rationally you know it's not. But what you're often experiencing is not a real connection, it's a loop. Uncertainty, again, creates anticipation, anticipation releases dopamine, dopamine increases desire, the lack of resolution keeps the cycle going. I just want to really like make this a core point. Your inability to move on from this person, even though you know there's no future, even though you know they don't feel the same way, is not because you lack willpower. It's because there are insanely powerful chemical loops bringing you back again and again and again, hoping, expecting, wanting a different outcome.
较低的阈值，这让你感觉非常非常好。这些小小的峰值后面跟着巨大的崩溃。但是对事物会改变的期待或期望，对你的下一次互动、你的下一个时刻可能就是他们爱上你的那一刻的期待，让你一直欲罢不能。每一个微小的关注信号，一条短信、一个眼神、一个连接的时刻，都会让人感到不成比例的奖赏，因为它是不可预测的。这种不一致性实际上增强了依恋。随着时间的推移，你的大脑，就像你处于一种如此高度的渴望状态中，以至于它感觉像是真正的吸引。焦虑、痴迷、兴奋，它是如此强烈，这种强度显然深深地印在了我们的大脑中，
So you are biologically being hijacked by this kind of relationship. It is a relationship. There's another reason we want people who don't want us back. It's the promise of the ultimate self-worth achievement. If they were to eventually want us back, everyone who has ever rejected us, every bad feeling we have about ourselves, every moment of unrequited love, Every second we've doubted ourselves, it would all be proven false. We would finally have confirmation that we were good enough for somebody, that we can prove ourselves to somebody who initially dismissed us, that we do have value, that somebody does want us.
因此，它可能会被误认为是真正的化学反应，对你的内心来说是非常非常真实的事情，即使理性上你知道并非如此。但你经常经历的不是真正的连接，而是一个循环。不确定性，再次强调，创造了期待，期待释放多巴胺，多巴胺增加欲望，缺乏结果让这个循环继续下去。我只想真正把这一点作为一个核心点。你无法放下这个人，即使你知道没有未来，即使你知道他们的感觉不同，也不是因为你缺乏意志力。而是因为有极其强大的化学循环一次又一次地把你拉回来，怀着希望、期待、渴望一个不同的结果。
The thing is, the person who doesn't want us holds all the power right now. Like they hold all the power because we can't give ourselves the validation of being wanted by somebody else, especially not by them. Like only they can give us that. Of course, we can like think that we're great. But we think that they're wonderful. We think that they're an amazing person. Like if we like somebody, we obviously have a great opinion of them.
所以你在生物学上被这种关系劫持了。这确实是一种关系。我们想要那些不想要我们的人还有另一个原因。那是终极自我价值成就的承诺。如果他们最终想要我们，每一个曾经拒绝过我们的人，我们对自己的每一个不好的感觉，每一刻的单相思，每一个我们怀疑自己的时刻，都会被证明是假的。我们终于得到了确认，证明我们对某人来说足够好，我们可以向一个最初拒绝我们的人证明自己，我们确实有价值，确实有人想要我们。
We think they have good taste. We think they're cool. So them not liking us feels like we didn't make the cut based on their standards. We must not be all that good in the eyes of this great individual. This cuts really deep to the core of our own self-acceptance and worth assessment. Deep down, if this person has rejected us, we believe that means they must see themselves as better than us or deserving of more, or deserving of somebody who is, or of having standards that we can't meet. The thing is, this obviously makes us feel awful, right? Because we don't feel
问题是，那个不想要我们的人现在掌握了所有的权力。就像他们掌握了所有的权力一样，因为我们无法赋予自己被别人需要的认可，特别是不能由他们来赋予。就像只有他们能给我们那种认可。当然，我们可以认为自己很棒。但我们认为他们很棒。我们认为他们是一个了不起的人。如果我们喜欢某人，我们显然对他们有很高的评价。
like we made the cut. It also creates a strange competitiveness in us, whereby if we were to eventually convince them to like us, this would prove that we must be good. we must be worth something. That's a great feeling to be striving for. I fully believe people who are high achievers, very ambitious, very smart, fall a lot harder for unrequited love. I know I've said it before. It's genuinely a hill I will die on. You are so used to having to work for anything that you want, to having to put in long hours, to strive. You may even live by the philosophy that like anything worth having won't be easily. So why wouldn't that be the same for love? You feel that way for work. You feel that way in your ambition at school in your goals. This belief
我们认为他们品味很好。我们认为他们很酷。所以他们不喜欢我们，让我们觉得我们没有达到他们的标准。在这个伟大的人眼中，我们一定不是那么好。这深深触及了我们自我接纳和价值评估的核心。内心深处，如果这个人拒绝了我们，我们就会认为这意味着他们一定觉得自己比我们更好，或者配得上更多，或者配得上某个，或者拥有我们无法达到的标准。问题是，这显然让我们感觉糟糕，对吧？因为我们觉得自己
transfers over to relationships as well. If it's easy, it's not worth it because things that are quality make you work harder. So that's why we don't want the person who wants us. They didn't make us work hard for it. We want the person who obviously has value because it's not immediately accessible. That doesn't apply to love though, right? Our mind is taking a standard we set for everything else and being like, well, this must be the same here. Love is something that is actually and should probably flow very naturally compared to everything else in life that makes us really work and strive and sweat. There's also this concept in psychoanalytic psychology that I really think you should know called the object of desire. This was first discussed by a French psychologist
没有达到标准。这也在我们心中创造了一种奇怪的竞争力，如果我们最终能说服他们喜欢我们，这就能证明我们一定是好的。我们一定是有价值的。那是一种为之奋斗的绝佳感觉。我完全相信那些高成就者、非常雄心勃勃、非常聪明的人，更容易陷入单相思。我知道我以前说过。这绝对是我至死也要捍卫的观点。你已经习惯了为你想要的任何东西付出努力，习惯了长时间工作，习惯了奋斗。你甚至可能信奉这样一种哲学：任何值得拥有的东西都不会轻易得到。那么为什么爱不也是这样呢？你在工作中会有这种感觉。你在学校的雄心壮志中、在你的目标中会有这种感觉。这种信念
called Jacques Lacan. Hopefully my French accent is good. His idea is that when we see something we can't obtain, whether that is an expensive house on Zillow, a lifestyle of an influencer, or a person who we think is great, we begin to project this idea that this is where happiness, self-worth, fulfillment must be. This thing, this is the thing that would make us happy. And the fact we don't have it is why we're unhappy. It kind of gives us a reason for our insecurity, a reason for our sadness, our lack of fulfillment that isn't internal. Like, it's not because we're doing something wrong. It's not because we're unhappy. It's because we're missing this thing. And once we have this thing, all of our wildest dreams will come true. This is a big explanation for why we long and why
也会转移到人际关系中。如果很容易，那就不值得，因为有品质的东西会让你付出更多努力。这就是为什么我们不想要那个想要我们的人。他们没有让我们为此付出努力。我们想要那个显然有价值的人，因为那不是触手可及的。但这并不适用于爱情，对吧？我们的思想把为其他一切设定的标准拿来，然后觉得，嗯，这里肯定也一样。爱情实际上是一种，并且可能应该非常自然地流淌的东西，相比于生活中那些让我们真正努力、奋斗和流汗的其他事情。在精神分析心理学中还有一个概念，我认为你真的应该知道，叫做欲望的对象。这最初是由一位法国心理学家
we yearn. We know we'll never have this thing. And therefore, it's easy to place all of our hopes and desires and long-loss wishes like at its feet. A person, a relationship, especially when we know we cannot have is like the perfect candidate for this elusive role of representing everything that would fix our lives for us because love is painted that way is something that is everything. I also think that the very fact that this person doesn't want us makes them mysterious and that mystery means we can create whatever fantasy we want of them. You know, they're flawless in our minds. We actually, because we aren't around them as much because we don't have a relationship,
雅克·拉康讨论的。希望我的法语口音还不错。他的观点是，当我们看到我们无法获得的东西时，无论是Zillow上一栋昂贵的房子，一个网红的生活方式，还是一个我们认为很棒的人，我们开始把这种想法投射到上面，认为这就是幸福、自我价值、满足感所在的地方。这个东西，这就是能让我们快乐的东西。我们没有它，就是我们不快乐的原因。它在某种程度上为我们的不安全感、我们的悲伤、我们缺乏满足感提供了一个外部的原因。就像，这不是因为我们做错了什么。这不是因为我们不快乐。这是因为我们缺少了这个东西。一旦我们有了这个东西，我们所有的疯狂梦想都会成真。这是对我们为何渴望和向往的一个重大解释。
Like, we can create whatever fantasy version of a soulmate we want, even if it's not real. Like, we can build them into whatever we want them to be. And the sides of somebody that are only revealed in a relationship, the sides that are kind of ugly or not likable, those aren't there. And so our obsession only deepens because we believe we found the last person on earth who might actually be perfect. the idealized version of somebody that is that you are at a distance from, it's a lot easier to love and a lot easier to be obsessed with. The thing is, if you were to get to know them,
我们知道我们永远不会拥有这个东西。因此，很容易把我们所有的希望、欲望和失落已久的愿望放在它的脚下。一个人，一段关系，尤其是当我们知道我们无法拥有时，就像是这个难以捉摸的角色的完美候选人，代表着一切能够修复我们生活的的东西，因为爱情被描绘成那样，是一种包罗万象的东西。我还认为，这个人不想要我们的事实本身使他们变得神秘，而这种神秘意味着我们可以对他们产生任何我们想要的幻想。你知道，他们在我们心中是完美的。实际上，因为我们不怎么和他们在一起，因为我们没有恋爱关系，
they probably wouldn't be like that. But when somebody is distant or unavailable, they remain undefined. And undefined people can be come, be present, be seen as anything we want them to be. So that makes it a lot harder to move on. There are a few other explanations for why unrequited love keeps us hooked. Obviously attachment theory is a big one. I'm not going to talk about it today though because I just feel like we've done so many episodes on it that you can go and find. I just feel like it's such a big topic.
我们可以创造出任何我们想要的灵魂伴侣的幻想版本，即使它不是真的。就像，我们可以把他们塑造成我们想要的任何人。而一个人只在恋爱关系中才会展现的一面，那些有些丑陋或不讨人喜欢的一面，并不存在。因此，我们的痴迷只会加深，因为我们相信我们找到了地球上最后一个可能真正完美的人。理想化版本的某人，当你与他保持距离时，爱起来要容易得多，痴迷起来也容易得多。问题是，如果你去了解他们，
The other thing though and the other big explanation is this one particular effect I don't see people talking about, which is the zygarnic effect. Zygarnic effect. our brain hates unfinished stories. And so our brain will keep them open until we get the solution. This means we genuinely cannot move on until we feel like we have closure. Until we know why they don't want us. We know that somebody else will.
不过，另一个重要的解释是，有一个很多人似乎都没有注意到的特殊效应，那就是蔡格尼克记忆效应。蔡格尼克效应。我们的大脑讨厌未完成的故事，因此大脑会一直敞开心扉，直到我们找到答案。这意味着，在觉得事情有了了结之前，我们真的无法向前看。直到我们弄清楚为什么他们不想要我们。我们知道总会有别人明白这一点。
This is what is happening when you want somebody who, and you find yourself wanting them more after they don't want you back. Like they've done studies on this where they'll get somebody to do a task and they'll interrupt them halfway through and then they'll get them to do another task. and this person will be like, I can't do this. I'm fixated. I'm fixated on finishing this unfinished thing. And that is literally what happens with relationships that are unfinished as well. How can I move on when this door isn't being officially closed? And finally, I also think unrequited love gives us a purpose. When everything else in your life feels uncertain, having text to analyze, small moments to replay,
当你渴望某个人，而在对方拒绝你之后，你发现自己更加渴望他们时，发生的就是这种情况。就像他们做过这方面的研究一样，他们会让某人做一项任务，然后在进行到一半时打断他们，接着让他们去做另一项任务，这个人就会觉得：“我做不到，我满脑子都是这个，我满脑子都在想着完成这个未完成的事情。”这实际上也正是未完成的感情中所发生的情况。当这扇门没有被正式关闭时，我又怎么能向前迈进呢？最后，我还认为，单恋给了我们一个目标。当你生活中的一切都感到充满不确定性时，有可以分析的短信，有可以反复回味的微小瞬间，
somebody to yearn for gives you like the greatest kind of object to fixate on. It feels so important because like what's more important than love? It's an amazing, amazing distraction. Not having that someone, that fixation point can make life feel kind of boring and meaningless. And so sometimes our obsession with somebody is rather grounding. It's purpose giving. It's motivating, especially when, you know, you are a little bit lonely. You're struggling with work. You don't really have a purpose. It's like, well, why does that matter if I have this?
有一个可以思念的人，会给你提供一种最好的倾注对象。这感觉太重要了，因为还有什么比爱情更重要呢？这是一种绝佳的、绝佳的分散注意力的方式。没有了那样一个人、那个固着点，生活就会变得枯燥无味、毫无意义。因此，有时我们对某人的痴迷其实相当有根基，它能赋予我们目标，给我们以动力，尤其是当你感到有点孤独、工作不顺心、且没有真正的人生目标时。它就像是在说：“好吧，只要我有这个，那又有什么关系呢？”
If I can win this person over, it's all going to be okay. Love is like the best thing out there. If I find love, all of this other stuff is going to take care of itself. So that's the explanation for why you find yourself in the state of limerence and obsession with an unrequited figure, why somebody not liking you back is so, like, deeply powerful for our brain. Let's continue this conversation and talk about what to do about it, including some more controversial advice I have for you.
“如果我能赢得这个人的心，一切都会好起来的。爱情是世上最美好的事情。如果我找到了真爱，所有这些其他的事情都会迎刃而解。”这就是为什么你会陷入对一个冷漠之人的痴迷和迷恋状态的解释，为什么别人不喜欢你对我们的大脑来说具有如此深远而强大的影响。让我们继续这个话题，聊聊对此该做些什么，包括一些我给你的更具争议性的建议。
Stay with us. You have the desire to help us? The College, the Citi, you offer the program Dependence and Sentental Mental. Acquare the competences essential for accompany and support the people confronted to health mental and dependence. Construise a career enriching
请继续收听。你有帮助我们的愿望吗？西蒂学院为你提供“依赖症与心理健康”项目。获取陪伴和支持面对心理健康与依赖症人群的核心能力。构建丰富的职业生涯，
to service of the community francophone of all the country. Don't know their quality in French, it's possible with The City. Visit the Collage Latcate.C.A. right now.
服务于全法兰克语社区。想在法语水平上有所精进？西蒂学院可以帮你实现。立即访问 CollageLatcate.C.A。
An initiative of the Consortium National of Formation in Health in Canada. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever.
这是加拿大法语健康国家联合会的一项倡议。当时，感觉这一切仿佛永远不会结束。
I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell
我以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。那双眼睛里空洞洞的，什么也没有。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓得魂飞魄散。
out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, yeah. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so.
那是你的第一个谋杀案吗？是的，没错。敢说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸和谋杀。简直不能再糟糕了。我想也是。
Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevent and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
恶魔，醒醒吧。我是目睹克雷文和德皮波谋杀案发生的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说我没罪。我要把官司打到底。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔的采石场》。
And to hear the devil's quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartum depression.
要在Apple Podcasts上无广告收听《恶魔的采石场》并获取独家内容，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅LaVa for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《与霍达·科特比的欢乐101》的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，比如女演员奥利维娅·芒分享她是如何战胜严峻的健康挑战的。我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁。
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a part of it's exciting because their new star is Javier Ticharito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death?
但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《与霍达·科特比的欢乐101》。这其中一部分令人兴奋，因为他们的超级新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。每个人都把我当作一名足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我依然在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系和情绪共存，从我出生起就是这样。而且我仍然有那么多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？
How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barcelona? From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine.
你如何面对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？从日常平凡到深刻非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每一件事都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。
This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends. Where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has a order perfect and everything is just. Wait me, I'm going to pressur me, but me will go to go back. We are here to connect. El Chicharito. And together with Iha Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary.
这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈。脆弱得以展现，阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生教训得以分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等我，我要给自己施加压力，但我会回去的。我们来到这里是为了建立连接。小豌豆。我们将与iHeart Radio一起，化平凡为非凡。
Stay close. It's a crack. Wow. Listen to learning to be human or IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is. Getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is. getting a new one put up in its place.
请继续关注。真棒。在iHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。这里有一件事本不该如此复杂：拆除种族主义者的雕像。这里还有另一件事本该比现在容易得多：在原地竖起一尊新雕像。
As long as there's a politics of race in America, there's going to be a politics of remembering the civil war. To get to school, I had to go down Robert Lee Boulevard. Get to the grocery store, I had to go down Jefferson Davis Parkway. If you're an historian and you leave out half of what the history is, you're not doing your job. I'm Akila Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 goes deep on both of those things. The fights, the politics, the people who won,
只要美国存在种族政治，就会存在关于内战记忆的政治。要去学校，我必须走罗伯特·李大道。要去杂货店，我必须走杰斐逊·戴维斯公园大道。如果你是一位历史学家，却漏掉了历史的一半，那你就是在渎职。我是阿基拉·休斯，《反叛精神》第二季将深入探讨这两件事。抗争、政治、获胜的人，
and my personal campaign to add something to the Kentucky State House that's actually worth the wall space. We are more than our bodies. We contain essence. We contain spirit. How do you represent that? They are just fueling a fire that is really catching. You'll see what I mean.
以及我为在肯塔基州议会大厦增加一件真正值得占据墙面空间的东西而开展的个人活动。我们不仅仅是我们的身体。我们包含着本质。我们包含着精神。你如何表现这一点？他们只是在火上浇油，而且这团火势正猛。你会明白我的意思的。
Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, hear me out. There is nothing wrong with a fun, a fun little crush. Honestly, I think it's a soul need. I think it's probably good for the soul. to feel hopeful about the state of love and hopeful that there are people out there who you would want to meet and get to know and fall for. I read this really great psychology today piece that
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《反叛精神》第二季。好吧，听我解释。有一个有趣的小迷恋并没有什么错。老实说，我认为这是一种心灵的需求。我认为这对灵魂大概是有益的，能够对爱情的状态抱有希望，并相信外面确实有你想去遇见、去了解并与之坠入爱河的人。我读过一篇《今日心理学》上的精彩文章，
talks about how crushes make us feel excited. They keep us caring about how we present to the world, which is probably important from an evolutionary perspective. They keep us optimistic. They're also just like once again, they're fun. Like a crush is fun and that can be all that it is. liking somebody that you know, like you have no intention of actually ever doing anything about it. Like, you have no intention of like asking them out. Like, it's, it's not that serious. Like, that's fun. It's like what being in your 20s is about. Um, that's when I personally think, like, situations like this are okay. Like, you know they're not going to hurt you because they don't want you back so you can kind of just observe. But when they dance into like dangerous territory
里面谈到迷恋是如何让我们感到兴奋的。它们让我们继续在意自己向世界呈现的形象，从进化的角度来看，这或许很重要。它们让我们保持乐观。而且它们再次证明，它们很有趣。就像暗恋很有趣一样，而且它可以仅仅只是暗恋。喜欢一个你认识的人，就好像你根本没打算对这段关系采取任何行动。就像，你根本没打算约他们出去。这没那么严重。这很有趣。这就是二十多岁时该有的样子。嗯，这就是为什么我个人认为，类似这样的情况是可以接受的。就像，你知道他们不会伤害你，因为他们不喜欢你，所以你基本上可以只去观察。但当它们悄然进入危险领域时，
emotionally is when we encounter this like objective desire situation where once again, we think of them as the savior, we put our first name next to their last name, like we lose ourselves to our obsession. What they do, how they choose to treat us, whether we see them or not, dictates our entire emotional state. And we do just silly things. I've been there. I've done so many silly things for people who've never showed any interest in me.
在情感上，我们就会遇到这种客观欲望的状况，正如我们再次想的那样，我们把他们当作救世主，我们把自己的名字写在他们的姓氏旁边，我们因痴迷而迷失了自我。他们的所作所为、他们选择如何对待我们、我们是否能见到他们，决定了我们整个的情绪状态。我们会做一些极其愚蠢的事。我也经历过。我曾为那些从未对我表现出任何兴趣的人做过很多愚蠢的事。
And that is a problem and that does require some examination. And this is when we need to break the spell. here's how I think we should go about it or you should go about it based on some of the psychological principles, the same psychological principles that got you hooked in the first pace. Identify firstly what it is about them that they represent that you think you are otherwise missing. Unrequited love is rarely just about the person. It's about what they symbolize.
这是一个问题，确实需要进行一些审视。这就是我们需要打破魔法的时候。以下是我认为你应该如何去做，或者基于一些心理学原理你应该如何去做的建议，这些心理学原理正是当初让你深陷其中的同类原理。首先，明确他们所代表的特质中，有哪些是你觉得自己身上所缺失的。单恋很少仅仅关于这个人本身，它关乎他们所象征的意义。
When you feel intensely drawn to somebody who doesn't want you back, your brain isn't just responding to them as an individual. It's responding to what they represent in your psychological world that is absent. This is a concept closely, closely tied to Freud's concept of projection and idealization. Again, as we said before, we take the qualities we admire, we crave, we feel only lack, we place them in this other person, and in that way we turn them into an emotional solution. We turn them into like the golden band-aid. maybe what you're lacking and the reason you're attracted to this person is because you're not
当你强烈地被一个不想要你的人吸引时，你的大脑不仅是在对他们作为个体做出反应，而是在对他们在你心理世界中代表的、缺席的部分做出反应。这个概念与弗洛伊德的投射和理想化概念紧密相连。同样，正如我们之前所说，我们把那些我们钦佩、渴望、感到自己唯一缺乏的品质投射到这个人身上，通过这种方式，我们把他们变成了一种情感的解决方案。我们把他们变成了某种黄金创可贴。也许你所缺乏的、以及你被这个人吸引的原因是因为你不够
confident and this person is so confident so you feel like if they were to be with you you'd finally feel good about yourself the thing is if your self-esteem were to improve if you were to realize how amazing you actually are your need and desire for them you would be surprised by how quickly it would disappear maybe what you're lacking is a sense of security right now we just spoke about this, but this person might represent what it would feel like to have certainty in your life or in a partner. And it kind of like not have to worry about it anymore. You've got your person, it's all sorted. And you're just really craving something that is certain, something that is going to go right and that is secure. Maybe what they represent is again a purpose, which you otherwise feel
自信，而这个人非常自信，所以你觉得如果能和他们在一起，你最终就会对自己感觉良好。问题是，如果你的自尊心提高了，如果你意识到自己实际上有多么优秀，你对他们的需求和渴望就会以你意想不到的速度消失。也许你缺乏的是当下的安全感，我们刚刚谈过这一点，但这个人可能代表了在生活中或在伴侣身上拥有确定性会是怎样的一种感受。并且有点像不用再为此担心了。你已经有了属于你的人，一切都搞定了。而你只是非常渴望某些确定的东西，某些会顺利发展且有安全感的东西。也许他们代表的又是一个目标，而你平时觉得
you don't have. There's so many things that somebody else can represent. They can represent excitement, they can represent belonging, they can embody the kind of person you want to be. And like, so by, by admiring them from afar, sometimes what's happening is you unconsciously feel closer to this ideal version of you through your like temporary one-sided attachment to them. What are you seeking to fulfill? What does this person offer that you don't think you can offer yourself right now? There's this theory called the self-expansion model.
自己并不具备这个目标。其他人可以代表很多东西。他们可以代表兴奋，可以代表归属感，他们可以体现出你想成为的那种人。所以，通过远远地欣赏他们，有时发生的事情是，你通过对他们这种短暂的、单方面的依恋，在无形中觉得自己更接近理想中的自己。你在试图满足什么？这个人提供了什么，是你觉得自己现在无法提供给自己的？有一个理论叫做自我扩展模型。
I don't know if it's a self-expansion model full stop or self-expansion model of love, but it was like one of the first psychological theories of love. And it essentially says we are mainly attracted to people that grow and expand our sense of self and that who we think would make us better people. So it's not wrong that you want this person who you think would make you better or who you think is great and has resources and has a great personality and it's cool. That's not wrong. It's actually probably why you like that. them in the first place. But what's to say you aren't capable of self-expansion through friendship right now, through your own self-exploration, through mentorship, or through somebody else
我不知道这是全面意义上的自我扩展模型还是爱情的自我扩展模型，但它是最早的爱情心理学理论之一。它本质上说的是，我们主要被那些能够增长和扩展我们自我感的人所吸引，我们认为这些人会让我们成为更好的人。所以，你想找这个你认为会让你变得更好、或者你认为很优秀、很有资源、很有个性且很酷的人，这并没有错。这并没有错。这大概正是你一开始喜欢他们的原因。但有什么理由说你现在不能通过友情、通过自我探索、通过导师或者通过其他真正想要你的人来实现自我扩展呢？
that actually wants you? We get fixated on this person thinking that they're the only ones who can expand us for getting all these other options. When you identify what you think it is that this person would fulfill what need or absence you need them for, you can get to work kind of feeling it in other ways. Secondly, it's a important to like create physical distance in any way that you can and just flush this person out with as many hobbies like social engagements opportunities as you can now some people would say this is just plain or distraction maybe it's even avoidance like i see the argument and i would agree with them because it kind of is that's the whole point like it is distraction it is trying to
我们全神贯注于这个人，认为他们是唯一能够扩展我们的人，却忘记了所有这些其他的选择。当你确定了你认为这个人能够满足的需求或你所需要的缺失感之后，你就可以开始努力通过其他方式来感受它。其次，尽可能在任何方面创造物理距离，并用尽可能多的爱好、社交活动、机会来把这个人从脑海中冲刷出去。现在有些人会说这只是单纯的分散注意力，也许这甚至是逃避，我能理解这种观点，我也赞同他们，因为某种程度上确实如此，但这正是重点所在——它就是分散注意力，它就是试图
get away from the problem and the initial months of trying to move past this person you need to be continuously breaking the association between them and the feeling of anticipation and dopamine. Basically, that's what we need to do. What you're experiencing when you get a rush or a thrill anytime you see them, hear from them, think about them is a conditional emotional response. So you need to focus on extinguishing that by, well, extinguishing that response by creating more powerful ones and also by not giving into the desire to reach out or to see them or to be with them. From a psychological perspective, this has a name, it's called extinction.
远离问题。在试图忘掉这个人的最初几个月里，你需要不断地打破他们与期待感和多巴胺之间的联系。基本上，这就是我们需要做的事情。每当你看到他们、听到他们的消息、想起他们时，你所经历的那种冲动或兴奋是一种条件性情绪反应。因此，你需要专注于通过建立更强大的反应来消除这种反应，同时也不要向想要联系他们、见到他们或与他们在一起的渴望妥协。从心理学的角度来看，这有一个名字，叫做消退。
Basically, when a learned association weakens because the expected reward is no longer delivered, like we stop anticipating it. The thing is extinction doesn't happen just like because passively. Like if you just sit in the absence, your brain often actually increases craving in an attempt to motivate you to get the reward back. that's why people relapse, that's why they text them, that's why they check their socials or they spiral, when they just think that ignoring them is extinguishing the connection, instead you have to actively compete with the old association and give your brain new sources of reward,
基本上，当习得的联结因为不再获得预期的奖励而减弱时，就像我们不再期待它一样。问题在于，消退不会仅仅因为被动而发生。如果你只是坐在那里任由其缺席，你的大脑往往实际上会增加渴望，试图以此激励你把奖励拿回来。这就是为什么人们会复发，这就是为什么他们会发短信给对方，为什么他们会查看对方的社交媒体或者陷入情绪失控，当他们仅仅以为忽略对方就能消灭这种联系时，相反，你必须积极地与旧的联结竞争，为你的大脑提供新的奖励来源。
new people who give you connection without anxiety, more social things in your day, connecting with old friends, making new friends, activities, adventures, side quests that, like, create genuine dopamine, novelty, like creativity, planning for something, training for something, reaching for a goal, being in environments that don't carry their memory. It's also important to understand that, again, I want to really state this, this kind of distraction is very different from long-term emotional avoidance. You're allowed, I think, in these moments to still think about them, you're not suppressing or denying your feelings forever. You're just creating enough distance so that the intensity is manageable and so that you know that they are not the only thing
结识能带来不焦虑陪伴的新朋友，在日常生活中多安排些社交活动，与老友联络，结交新朋友，进行各种活动、冒险，去做那些能产生真正的多巴胺、新鲜感、创造力、为某事做规划、为某事进行训练、达成目标、身处没有负面回忆的环境中的支线任务。同样重要的是要明白，我真的想再次强调这一点，这种分心与长期的情感回避有着本质的区别。我认为，在这些时刻，你依然可以去想他们，你并不是在永远压抑或否认自己的感受。你只是在创造足够的距离，让这种强度变得可以承受，同时也让你明白，他们并不是唯一
that's going to make you happy or make you fulfilled. Once the emotional charge is lower, you can reflect more clearly. You can process what actually happened. And you can understand the dynamic without being pulled back into it, I think, as well. The next thing I do, I haven't done it in a while, but I think it's absolutely essential. Have an imaginary breakup day where you do everything you do if you had actually been in a relationship with this person and broken up. Take a sick day, go out for a long, sad walk in the woods, or in nature, write them a long letter, have a hot shower, cry, eat ice cream, drink some wine, watch La La Land, cry some
能让你快乐或感到充实的人。一旦情绪的冲击减弱，你就能更清晰地反思。你可以理清到底发生了什么。而且我认为，你也能在不被情绪重新拽入其中的情况下理解这种动态。我做的下一件事，虽然我有一段时间没做了，但我认为这绝对至关重要。举行一个假想的分手日，做所有如果你真的和这个人谈过恋爱并分了手之后会做的事。请个病假，去树林里或大自然中进行一次漫长而悲伤的散步，写一封长信，洗个热水澡，哭泣，吃冰淇淋，喝点红酒，看《爱乐之城》，再哭
more. Grieve them in the way that you deserve to. basically like have a funeral for the love story that you imagined with them, this person. This is so effective. It's so effective because it essentially creates the ending to counteract the zygonic effect. Like we spoke about this before, like that unended story, your brain operates best when a story has a beginning. It has a middle or a lesson. and it has an end.
一会。以你应得的方式为他们感到悲伤。基本上就像为你在脑海中与这个人想象的爱情故事举行一场葬礼。这太有效了。之所以如此有效，是因为它本质上创造了一个结局来对抗蔡格尼克记忆效应。就像我们之前谈过的那样，对于那个未完结的故事，当一个故事有开端时，你的大脑运作得最好。它有一个中间过程或教训，而且它有一个结局。
For unrequited love, you don't get the end. So you have to provide it for yourself in order to then move forward and discover the lesson as to why this particular individual is so desirable to you. When you give yourself a day to properly, intentionally, grieve, be dramatic, even if you don't think you deserve to, like just do it. You're doing something very psychologically sophisticated. You're taking something abstract and unresolved, which is this connection, this one-sided connection,
对于单相思，你得不到结局。所以你必须为自己提供一个结局，以便继续前进，并找出为什么这个特定的人对你如此具有吸引力的教训。当你给自己一整天的时间去适当地、有意地悲伤、表现得戏剧化一点，即使你认为自己不配这样做，也去这么做吧。你正在做一件心理学上非常成熟的事。你把某种抽象且未解决的事情，也就是这种联系、这种单方面的联系，
and you're making it concrete, you're saying this happened, this was real, and you're giving it a finale. You are ritualizing something that would otherwise feel very confusing. You are giving it the ending that you deserve and that your brain needs to clearly see in order to move forward. Finally, once you've provided yourself with the ending, this is when you can start to reframe the situation from loss, interlesson. And I know that sounds corny. But I think creating an ending is one level of moving forward.
变得具象化，你是在说这事情发生过，这是真实的，你在给它一个大结局。你是在将某种原本会让人感到非常困惑的事情仪式化。你给了它你应得的、也是你的大脑为了继续前进所清晰需要的结局。最后，一旦你为自己提供了一个结局，这时你就可以开始把这种处境从“损失”重新定义为“教训”。我知道这听起来很老套。但我认为创造一个结局是向前迈进的一个层面。
Finding the meaning is the next level and is what allows us to integrate this experience. And really, it's what allows us to grow as individuals, which probably doesn't sound very meaningful to you right now, but is very important. Instead of asking, like, why didn't this work out? What's wrong with me? Like, what's wrong with me? You start asking. more constructive questions. Like, what did this actually reveal about what I need in a future person? What patterns did this bring to the surface? What am I being shown about my standards, my attachment style that doesn't sit right with me? What do I need to concentrate on within before I date somebody else or have another crush? This shift is really powerful because it transforms you
寻找意义是下一个层面，也是让我们能够整合这段经历的关键。说实话，这才是让我们作为个体成长的方式，现在这对你来说可能听起来没什么意义，但它非常重要。与其去问，比如，为什么这行不通？我有什么毛病？比如，我到底有什么毛病？你开始问一些更具建设性的问题。比如，这究竟揭示了我对未来伴侣的什么需求？这段经历把什么模式带到了水面之上？关于我的标准、我的依恋风格中有什么让我感到不对劲的地方，它向我展示了什么？在我跟别人约会或产生新的迷恋之前，我需要在自己内部集中精力解决什么？这种转变真的非常强大，因为它让你
from just being a passive participant who was hurt, who was kind of a victim of this person's decisions into an active interpreter of your experience and somebody who also, you have something to gain in the aftermath of this. You are not just somebody who was a victim, who lost, you left with a deeper connection to yourself and to your needs and your desires. And some people never get that. They are never challenged to look past attraction. It also prevents repetition. When you extract the lesson, you're far less likely to have to learn the lesson again and to chase the same dynamic because you understand what drew you to that person in the first place. I found that with the last person I dated before Tom.
从一个仅仅是受到伤害的被动参与者、一个有点像是这个人决定的受害者，转变为你自身经历的主动诠释者，并且你在这段经历的余波中也有所收获。你不仅仅是一个输掉的受害者，你带着与自己、与自己的需求和愿望更深的联系离开了。有些人永远得不到这一点。他们从未被挑战去超越吸引力去看待问题。这也防止了重复。当你提取出教训时，你就极不可能再次去吸取这个教训，也不太可能再去追求同样的动态，因为你明白了当初是什么吸引你去找那个人。我发现我在跟汤姆约会之前的最后一个人身上就是这样的。
I had like three or four of the same exact kind of semi-relationships back-to-back. And I don't think, like, well, I know I didn't actually sit with what they meant. Like I did the ritual of closing the chapter. I grieved. But I never was like, hey, maybe there's a pattern here. Like, maybe I'm just doing the same things and expecting. a different outcome. Finally doing that with the last guy is why I think I have the relationship I have now, because I was able to see, like, these people are literally the same people. This was the same
我接连有过三四次完全相同的这种半恋爱关系。我不认为，好吧，我知道我当时确实没有好好去体会这些经历意味着什么。就像我做过了结这一章的仪式一样。我悲伤过了。但我从来没有想过，嘿，这里可能存在某种模式。比如，也许我只是在重复做同样的事，却期望得到不同的结果。最后对最后一个男生这样做，才是我认为我现在能拥有这段关系的原因，因为我能够看出，这些人简直就是同一个人。这就是同一段
relationship. I just did it four times. I didn't learn the lesson. I will say, my final point on this, don't be unkind to yourself about the situation. Honestly, I think people who give and give and give love and are open to everybody and see the best in people and genuinely, like, care and love and have their heart on the line are what we need more of. As much as there are all these rules these days, and, like, there's this kind of idea that, like, to be successful in dating, you have to be cold and heartless. Humans aren't meant to despise love. They're not meant to be rational about love either. Like, that's been way too normalized, that we're meant to be these, like, cold professionals. situations of unrequited love and yearning and longing are one of the most human things you can
关系。我只是把它重复了四次。我没有吸取教训。我要说的是，我对此的最后一点看法，不要对自己太刻薄。老实说，我认为那些不断付出爱、对所有人敞开心扉、看到人们最好的一面、并且真心实意地关心、去爱、把心悬在刀刃上的人，正是我们现在更需要的人。尽管现在有各种各样的规则，而且有一种观点认为，要在约会中获得成功，你必须冷酷无情。人类不是为了蔑视爱而存在的。他们对爱也不应该是理性的。那种认为我们应该成为冷酷的专业人士的观念已经被过度正常化了。单相思和渴望的境况是人类最能体验到的事情之一，
experience. Like personally, I think it's spiritual almost. And I'd much rather, and I'd much rather you are, somebody who feels and loves deeply and gives deeply, even if that is unrecyclicated, then be somebody who cannot find it in their heart to care or who sees love as a game or who sees love as something to win and there are rules to follow and the first one to fall in love loses. Like, I don't think that's particularly healthy. As much as people talk about how unrequited love is, like, I don't know, unhealthy and irrational and as much as it probably is really frustrating and, like, goes against many forms of, like, reasoning, is it really that bad to, like, care deeply about somebody and to see somebody's potential? Like, I think that the
就像我个人认为它几乎是具有精神意义的。我宁愿，我宁愿你是一个能够深刻感受、深刻爱、深刻付出的人，哪怕这种付出没有得到回应，也不要做一个在内心深处无法去关心别人的人，或者把爱视为一场游戏、把爱视为需要赢得的东西、有规则要遵循、谁先动心谁就输了的人。我不认为这特别健康。尽管人们说单相思是怎么怎么不健康、不理性，而且它可能真的很令人沮丧、违背了许多形式的理性，但深深地关心一个人并看到一个人的潜力，真的有那么糟糕吗？我觉得，
fact that you have that capacity for somebody who doesn't care about you means that when you find somebody who really does care about you and you feel this way about them as well, you're going to experience like a whole other depth. Like you think this is love. Imagine what love is going to feel like when you have that level of reciprocation. But I only think you can get there if you break this current bond and if you are able to investigate, and kind of reveal to yourself what it is about somebody who doesn't want you back that is so captivating to you. Is it the sense of achievement?
你对一个不关心你的人拥有这种能力，意味着当你找到一个真正关心你、你也对有这种感觉的人时，你将体验到完全不同的深度。如果你觉得这就是爱，想象一下当你拥有那种双向奔赴的回报时，爱会是什么感觉。但我认为，只有当你打破这种目前的羁绊，并且能够去探索、向自己揭示为什么一个不想要你的人对你有着如此巨大的吸引力时，你才能达到那种境界。这是一种成就感吗？
Is it that you think you need to earn love? Is it that they are representing a disregarded need that you have? I don't know, I can't really give you the answers, but I hope that, yeah, I hope that this is helpful. I hope that this information can get you a little bit closer. So that is our summary on why we love the people who do not love us back. And I've been there many, many times. So I feel for you.
是因为你觉得你需要赢得爱吗？是因为他们代表了你被忽视的需求吗？我不知道，我真的给不了你答案，但我希望，是的，我希望这能对你有所帮助。我希望这些信息能让你更接近答案。这就是我们关于“为什么我们爱那些不爱我们的人”的总结。而且我也经历过很多很多次。所以我对你感同身受。
And I hope that, I hope you know that, like, you do get through it. And you get through it in the way that you just, eventually you just realize how valuable that lesson is. And you feel really grateful that you had the opportunity to feel that way about anybody, even somebody who, like, didn't return the feeling because it's kind of spectacular. So I don't know if that's helpful if you're going through it right now, but it's just, I don't know, it's something that I wish I'd heard. So if you've made it this far, do me a favor. Leave a comment down below, what breakup movie are you going to watch tonight?
我希望，我希望你知道，你会挺过去的。你会以这种方式挺过去：最终你会意识到那个教训是多么珍贵。你会非常感激自己有机会对任何人有这种感觉，哪怕是一个没有回报这份感情的人，因为这种感觉简直太壮观了。所以如果你现在正经历这一切，我不知道这有没有帮助，但这只是，我不知道，这是我希望自己曾经听到过的话。所以如果你听到了这里，帮我个忙。在下方留言告诉我，你今晚打算看哪部失恋电影？
Or what breakup movie are you going to watch for the funeral of this could have been, what if relationship? I want to know. Mine was always La La Land. I've heard great things. about Notting Hill. Notting Hill, yeah, Notting Hill, the notebook, drop yours below, I guess those weren't stories of unrequited love, but La La La Land kind of was, and I think it's a great one. You can also follow us on Instagram. You can share this episode with a friend if you think they need to hear it. And if you didn't know, you can watch full episodes like this one on Netflix. Yeah, that's right. Netflix all over the world. If you want to watch a video version of this podcast, that is where you can find us.
或者为了这场“本可能发生、如果……会怎样”的关系的葬礼，你打算看哪部失恋电影？我想知道。我的总是《爱乐之城》。我听说《诺丁山》也很棒。《诺丁山》，对，诺丁山，《恋恋笔记本》，把你的片单留在下面吧，我猜那些不是单相思的故事，但《爱乐之城》某种程度上算是，而且我认为这是一部很棒的电影。你也可以在Instagram上关注我们。如果你觉得朋友需要听听这一期，你可以把这集分享给他们。如果你还不知道，你可以在Netflix上观看像这样的完整节目。没错。全世界的Netflix。如果你想看这个播客的视频版，那就是你可以找到我们的地方。
There's so many other links including, yeah, there's just so many other links in the description that you can check out. I feel for you. I'm sure you're really going through it right now, but it does get better. And yeah, I'm wishing you a lot of love and a lot of luck. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
还有很多其他的链接，包括，是的，简介里还有很多其他的链接你可以查看。我对你感同身受。我确信你现在真的很不好过，但情况会好起来的。是的，祝你收获满满的爱与好运。但在下期节目之前，照顾好自己，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会聊。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变黑了。
It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wait. up. I'm the woman saw the murder take place by Crevec and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive. But now, there's a new and,
这把我吓死了。邪恶，等等。醒醒。我是那个看到谋杀案由克雷维奇和德皮波实施的目击者。安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，在被判处最高刑期后显得镇定自若。我说，我没有罪。我要把这带进坟墓里。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨头谷》的恶魔采石场。快乐至关重要，但它也很难捉摸。但现在，有一种全新且，
an exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CVS.
令人兴奋的方式来开启你迈向更快乐生活之旅的方法。乔伊101。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索Joy 101并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比主持的《Joy 101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tornandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was.
每个人都把我当成足球运动员，但在其他任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情感共处，自从我出生以来就是这样。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的每件事都是自发的、真实的、纯粹的。只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·托尔纳德斯，在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。你的丈夫并不是你想象的那样。你的身体也不是你认为的那样。
Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. These are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets. He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. June is Black Music Month.
你的身份是由秘密的历史塑造的。我是丹妮·夏皮罗。这些只是我将在《家族秘密》第14季中探讨的几个惊人的故事。他有点把我推开说，让开。然后他走出了前门，跳上一辆车开走了。那是最后一次见到他。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《家族秘密》第14季。六月是黑人音乐月。
And on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that. I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped, like, 30 albums. We dropped, like, five right now. That's the rate we got to be going. Yep, that's a good attitude.
在《Drink Champs》播客中，我们正在与文化界最红的名字对话，比如斯韦·李。你意识到自己有多传奇吗？我很感激。我会看到它，但我心里想，天哪，我还有好多事要做呢。比如，普林斯，他发行了大概30张专辑。我们现在才发行了五张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。没错，这是一个好态度。
No matter the era, Drink Chams brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无论哪个时代，《Drink Champs》都会为你带来最大牌的人物和最无过滤的对话。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect播客网络的《Drink Champs》。这是一个iHeart播客。保证人类。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。